so you're mentioning anime are you a big
anime guy
i want to be i want to know
i want to have like that knowledge of
like the obscure [ __ ] but i'm such a
normie when it comes to anime but most
most conversation you'll ever have about
anime is normally conversation
you seem pretentious if you're like i
know this show no no no no
you do you guys do seem pretentious okay
okay like absolutely we have all this
knowledge and then we have like the same
like conversations 90 of the time anyway
because everyone's watching patients
yeah that's that's what i've learned
recently though is that like it doesn't
matter how much actual knowledge you
have on the medium because ninety
percent of the questions are going to be
so what did you think about the latest
attack on titan episodes yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna get to like that level right
yeah that new season of attack on titan
sucks i hate it i think it really i
think we're building up for the last one
well yeah yeah i'm being a bit harsh but
i just i feel like
carter we actually have it it was like
yeah yeah okay okay wait wait wait we're
getting into this now i i loved all the
first three seasons i got into the manga
i read all of it
was like whatever it was i haven't read
it i haven't read them so you you've
you're even like ahead of us in this
game then yeah ending i was like yeah
whatever and then i was like waiting for
it to happen i was like there's a couple
of good scenes in there and then it
happened i was like mapa are so much
better than that like
i feel like yeah jutsu kaizen came out
at like the same time and it's like
that's what you can do and this is what
we're getting right yeah you sound like
an anime fan yeah
most of them don't come here for anime
but yeah yeah oh my god they can speak
about it yeah yeah yeah because like i
didn't expect that you would just name
drop an anime studio because that's like
even you call yourself a casual anime
fan but that level of knowledge is even
more than most people i talk to you know
what you like to do to tyson as well
yeah i [ __ ] love jessica wow not like
him well
okay jiu-jitsu guys and story is like
whatever it's all like by the books
right
but i feel like it leans into that and
it's like you're just here to watch cool
animation you're just here to watch cool
fights yes it's like it's like this show
so much it's like naruto again but it's
like we cut out all the annoying [ __ ]
and just
it's like here's just fight scenes like
go for it yeah yeah also narrative
doesn't have like todo so like
that's like the best character
but but it does have kakashi which is
just basically gojo just like all over
again yeah you know yeah but yeah goku
is more marketable right
he's younger he's sexier
the younger sexier kakashi
but i didn't watch naruto for the first
time like last year yeah yeah i remember
you
oh how did that happen you watched
naruto the first time in 2021 well i did
too yeah because i remember you texting
me about it actually yeah like do you
think i should and i was like i mean you
go for it like yeah because my
girlfriend had watched it growing up and
that's right her into stuff and she's
she she lives in japan actually for a
long time oh really yeah
japanese and everything oh [ __ ] okay
she's she that was like that stuff was
what got her into it right right right
and then since i don't have any
nostalgia for i was like let's watch it
now and see if it holds up and we kind
of get a non-vice view on it yeah we did
like the non-filler sort of stuff like
yeah had listed on like reddit what like
the key wants to watch websites
dedicated yeah yeah
this is likely cut out like a third of
now yeah yeah yeah yeah i did that and i
was like it's still way too long yeah
yeah i was like we need a naruto kai to
come out
or a brotherhood
yeah because like i'm curious since
you've watched naruto last year i've
always thought that
it's like if you read the manga maybe it
would be a much better experience but i
think with the way anime production was
back then with a lot of filler not just
in episodes but within certain scenes it
would just just have dragged so much
do you think it's a good show
i think it is i think it has a lot of
heart to it and i think knowing the
pedigree that it has and the fact that
it started all of those trends that that
and dragon ball kind of like yeah
pioneered a lot of that like long drawn
out battle kind of [ __ ] yeah and the
fact that that's why i'm saying like
jujitsu kaizen feels like that but
modernized yeah yeah yeah they cut out a
lot of the nonsense but at the same time
they cut out most of that jack has more
of an in depth
like i said compared to like most people
i agree though jesus christ is just like
we're getting on with it [ __ ] yeah yeah
he's like the first episode like they
just get right into it whereas like yeah
you can tell shows from like 2000s when
they take their sweet [ __ ] time to
let anything happen oh like demon slayer
yeah yeah
it's like naruto but the exact same
where it's like all the annoying
characters all the filler [ __ ] all of
the like drawn out battles all right the
animation's so good just do that over
and over again was there any animes you
watched that you were like i'll give it
a shot and you were like very surprised
that you enjoyed it uh full metal
alchemist oh
i love that shirt yeah
it's it's amazing what's your favorite
character it's uh
the eds you know
everyone loves that [ __ ] he's right
[Laughter]
that's all the truth that was one had
heard a lot of yeah brotherhood
and then i watched it and i was like and
then it became my favorite of all time
oh because i was like it's just lean it
has a story to tell it gets in gets out
does it yeah i mean like i think like
for the anime community filmmaker
alchemist is kind of like the godfather
of like anime you know what i mean where
it's just like on the top of like every
top anime list of all time sacrilege
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
always on the top but because everyone
looks there and they're just like yeah
you know i guess it's probably the top
you know i'm not going to argue that
full metal alchemist like i i haven't
even seen it and i'm just like yeah it's
probably the top you know
that was why i watched it because it was
on the top of everyone's list now yeah
like sure i'll give it a shot and i was
like that makes sense yeah it feels
really unremarkable when you start
watching it but something about it just
keeps you so engaged and i i don't know
what quiet it is yeah actually it's just
like a really just put it on now we can
watch it
live live reaction right now my fans
have been trying to get me to watch for
like five six years now but like yeah as
someone actually asking you guys an
anime question as someone who hasn't
seen formatted alchemists you know you
have you have shows like attack on titan
like jiu-jitsu guys like demon slayer
which you know is very much critically
acclaimed but there's always like
there always seems to be like a group
that like is like anti like like like
tries to bring it down like the the
attack on titan is mid crew or the jiu
jitsu is mid crew or whatever but like
it just doesn't seem like that exists
for fullmetal alchemist
and i was just like why because i mean
for one it's like a genuinely good show
for one but i think it's also the fact
that now it's just put on such a
legendary status that it's like
i don't know there isn't i think it's
just a losing battle yeah if you go out
there and try to be that guy to be like
oh i think it's [ __ ] overrated or
whatever then everyone everyone i think
collectively is like okay sit down you
know
all right
it's just it's very lean like it has
like 65 episodes or something which
is like unheard of yeah it's just i
think because brotherhood came out it
did a lot of the heavy lifting because
the original one was kind of all over
the place yeah yeah yeah i had filler
stuff and everyone's like no one cares
just like here's like a decent story
starting to finish and it keeps like
having twist and twist and twist and the
pace is right so
yeah i think it was just like yeah just
a well-oiled machine that just you know
was
good enough interesting way to do this
yeah it was it was like
it was a well-oiled machine that just
like it just it was lubed the [ __ ] up it
was really smooth it worked perfectly
like everything it tried to do it did
well yeah those are pretty mature for
that era i think yeah there's still a
lot of like [ __ ] up scenes like even
in today's standards i think i think
even like in the mainstream i think
attacking titan's the only thing yeah
since that's like like people are
[ __ ] dying left right and center yeah
yeah i mean i think like attack on titan
is because most time when an anime gets
super super popular it's basically just
shonen jump it's you know shows like
juicy guys and demon slayer might hear
academia then attack on titan has been
like
the adult show i guess the most adult
show that's gotten as close to
mainstream as i think anime has gotten
even though it's still technically a
shown in mario yeah even yeah it is
technically
you know even though it technically is
published in a shown in magazine you
know it's it's seen as like more mature
especially you know you watch attack on
titan you're like this ain't no my hero
academia you know
definitely not do you have like a
favorite anime or manga then
uh favorite anime is full metal um it
used to be well it was like the first
season of one punch man i really loved
it
okay
okay like
a step down and i was like ah man you
could have just left it there it
wouldn't be fine
i think i think i know what your
favorite monger is
it's it's berserk right yeah yeah you
read berserk i feel like anyone who's
read berserk oh my god it's like top of
their list yeah yeah yeah i think it's
my favorite too because i i started and
again like full metal it was like top of
everyone's list now yeah like dark souls
like from soft or huge into them i was
like i'll give it a shot and then i had
the dark horse like
oh the thick ones the thick ones right
yeah one of those for a long time i was
like pandemics happening i'll finally
read it and then right just blasted
through the whole thing right yeah yeah
it's a shame i did it just pandemic as
well [ __ ] man i don't know
anyone who's like hasn't read it and
hears us talk like that it's like it's
it's worth it it's a lot of it's really
drawn out but it's like the only thing
that actually benefits from it i think
yeah absolutely yeah
yeah i i feel like the pacing is perfect
for the story it wants to tell it
doesn't it's not always like an action
fest but i feel like even like the
quieter moments just draw you in and
immerse you so much i think for me the
quieter moments of berserk is what i
enjoyed the most they hit really hard
yeah
there are some panels that are just like
so still and yet it's like i don't know
very intense at the same time it's very
difficult to explain but i just like the
scale of it because it sets up it's like
okay here's one bad guy and then he
follows that the entire way through
they're not like here's an ark with that
bad guy yeah someone else and then yeah
like reeling through it being like okay
when do we get back to good [ __ ] again
yeah it's like one one pillar the entire
way through and then the hero is like
it doesn't do that stuff like his power
level goes down and then it goes back up
and down it's like it's just very
consistent the whole way through and
it's more about the interpersonal drama
yeah than anything i knew it was special
because you know when you get like one
third of the way through something and
you're like oh no yeah oh no i'm getting
through this yeah it's gonna end i'm
gonna have to say when you go to the
golden age and it's like wait this isn't
a flashback
and he like that's the prologue that's
the prologue to the story
but yeah ashamed of that we're never
gonna see the end of it i still haven't
like i've still not brought up the
courage to read the final like few
chapters yeah i still haven't read the
final volume it's just yeah i'm like
sitting all the way it's a bigger weeb
than you guys did i've done it i read it
i bought it i bought it on release i got
like the special like uh like soundtrack
edition to it as well and but i'm just i
don't want to read it because i know
once i read that that's it there's no
more bizarre there's no
i totally agree have they said like
definitively if it's like done now or
not so
for a little while there was this rumor
that was going around where huxsensha
the the publishers were thinking about
continuing on the series and then it got
a ton of backlash online yeah just being
like nah dude just just let it go to
rest so right now we don't know yet
there is a possibility that they might
i personally don't want that because
yeah yeah because again like i haven't
read the last couple of chapters but i
heard that like the last couple of
chapters actually kind of has like a
somewhat round ending to it right yeah
it feels like you're getting very close
to the end yeah yeah just in a weird way
you can kind of predict what you think
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's yeah and i i
i don't feel like you know obviously
miura is like one of the arguably the
greatest mangaka who's ever lived you
know especially with his masterpiece
berserk and just who would even one who
would even want to try to even take up
that mantle you know like i wouldn't
want to be that person you know
um and like you know two it kind of just
feels to me at least it kind of feels
disrespectful if you know someone passes
away and you know there are some
instances that maybe you know some
people can continue on their vision if
they know what's going to happen but in
this case it just feels like such a
personal story that i don't really feel
like anyone can tell it but miura
himself yeah yeah yeah maybe we'll get
like a thing of like his notes or like
yeah yeah book of what he was thinking
would happen i feel like that's the best
way because then people can just make it
yeah fill in the blanks right i'd never
be disappointed by an ending that
doesn't happen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i saw something similar to that when i
went to the berserk exhibit though there
was like a cup that was trying to rub it
in now yeah
he's like let me let me flex on you
right now yeah
yeah there was like a there was like
kind of a glass cabinet of like a bunch
of like mirrors notes that were kind of
written down and there was like not
nothing really like concrete that went
after the manga yeah after where the
manga ended but um it was just really
cool to see like i guess it's like
thought process and like sketches on
like a bunch of [ __ ] because like it's
like really just super fine stuff like
very very basic shapes for characters
who then ended up being you know
characters like zod or like yeah you
know these like insane
pieces of art essentially in longer form
yeah um but yeah what was i going on
about yeah i went to the berserk
professional podcast
that wasn't even like a question that
was just his phone and go through
pictures
yeah you'll never see it
yeah so did you have a point joey or did
you just want to rub it into us yeah
that's all yeah it was a great example